Tokyo Mirage sessions sharp Fe is the
plot efficient Megami Tensei game with
Fire Emblem characters running around
and even though it occasionally feels
too ambitious it all just works
teens Itsuki and Tsubasa find themselves
wrapped up in an otherworldly war in
which Fire Emblem heroes and enemies
called mirages here are stealing
people's Performa the creative spirit
that resides in entertainers and
collecting it to take over the world
Itsuki and his gang recruit the likes of
Fire Emblem characters Crom Sheeta Tiki
and others to defeat the evil mirages
and save Shibuya from imminent
destruction a majority of your time in
sharp Fe is spent in dungeons each takes
on a unique appearance and features its
own twist on environmental puzzles one
area requests you find and help small
groups of mirages by lighting lamps in
their dressing rooms another is more
complicated requiring you crack
numerical codes to find the correct door
these puzzles take some time to unpack
and require you pay close attention to
your surroundings at first I was
frustrated with the difficulty as
there's a lot of backtracking and very
little direction but sharp Fe does not
hold your hand and I found it refreshing
the deeper I went the more I enjoyed my
dungeon time but sharp Effie's
gorgeously animated turn-based battles
are where the game really shines some
special attacks trigger a session which
allows for each hero to get in an extra
hit you are encouraged to take your time
seeking out attacks that trigger these
sessions this coupled with elemental
weaknesses and resistance in some enemy
types adds layers to each battle it's a
strategy oriented system and feels like
setting up the battlefield in a Fire
Emblem game what in autumn okay
three little saying take time to upgrade
your skills and weapons with debt Ria's
collected from defeated enemies each
mastered weapon will grant new or more
powerful healing and elemental abilities
and you can pick and choose which skills
to learn and which to forget which
allows for a range of customization in
each character's repertoire mirages 2
can change the class and become more
powerful leveling up Mirage is unlocking
and crafting new weapons and
cherry-picking what skills to learn is
all ripped from the Fire Emblem series
and it is expertly grafted onto sharp
Effie and when you're not in battle or
running around dungeons you can
strengthen your relationship with your
friends similar to the social links from
the persona games
running around shibuya together is sadly
relegated to fast travel between
buildings with the small city centre
explorable on foot you can also use the
Wii U gamepad like a cell phone where
text messages from your companions will
occasionally appear indicating new side
stories these add depth to Tokyo Mirage
sessions stories and give you additional
chances to level up your mirages and
gear while none of these side quests are
particularly challenging they do offer
more screen time with each Suki's
companions who prove far more
entertaining than our protagonists
himself and supply some fun worthwhile
world and character building time Tokyo
Mirage sessions sharp Fe is gorgeous fun
and a smart collaboration all around
backtracking through dungeons and
running up against tedious bosses can
bring the momentum down but after a few
dozen hours the semi ludicrous story and
system set in front of you feels so
comfortable together and this mashup of
developer atlases most popular franchise
and intelligent systems beloved strategy
RPG seems like it was just destined to
be yeah nah
he does it because you
you